Hi, I'm Chad Walquist. I'm an architect
at Palanteer. Today I have Nicholas from
Merc. He happens to lead all the data platforms.
Palanteer being one of them there. And so we're
going to talk about something called lightweight
transforms today, which is a pretty cool new
thing around processing and transforming data with
different compute engines. So, thanks for joining
me. Hi Chad. Thank you. Thanks for the invitation.
Yeah. So maybe just a little bit about what are
you responsible for at Merc and like what are you
doing? Yeah. So at Merc I'm uh leading the core
data platforms uh one of them being Palenteer
Foundry. I'm with the company since 2019. Um
and I think our partnership goes back even beyond
that. Um and um yeah, I'm really excited to share
a little bit about what we did together uh in
lightweight transforms. Yeah, and and lightweight
transform has been around for a while, but we've
really reintroduced it and and rearchitected a
lot of the back end here in the last few months
and honestly a lot from your feedback uh as a
customer and your willingness to work with us to
really iterate and make it what what it really
should be and what it is now. Um and so maybe just
as a precursor for everyone you know lightweight
transforms is allows you to have different types
of compute um inside of uh the platform. So
traditionally you would have like spark or flink
as the runtime as default inside of pounder today.
Now you can have those but you also can have
different um engines like duct db pullers data
fusion uh or even bring your own. So one of the
things that I know you're a big fan of duck DB and
you've been doing a lot of the transformation. So
maybe as we think through this like just to frame
it it's how do I like take the existing pipelines
I have or even new pipelines and you know what
is the benefit by moving to one of these engines
for you? Yeah, I think I think the the benefit is
definitely like the we we see a clear um reduction
in runtime of the of the transforms jobs which
translates to cost savings and uh so not only the
jobs are faster but but they also need less less
uh resources. Yeah. And so you get increased speed
and runtime the less resources to go run and like
what like for you like what is attributed to that?
Is it, you know, uh different node sizes? Is it is
it just the efficiency of the compute? Like what's
your perspective on why it's so much faster and
like how much faster are you seeing? Yeah, I'm
I'm see we we're seeing like across the board
10x improvements in terms of of the performance.
Um and I think I attribute it to like DDB or Polar
Stata Fusion, the the things you mentioned being
just another generation of of computer engines.
um leveraging the the hardware that is available
on the hyperscalers uh instances with NVME SSDs
uh high memory instances where actually for 90 or
even for us I get want to say 99% of the workloads
you don't need a distributed system uh you don't
need spark so there's no overhead um distributing
the task collecting the tasks and so on this it
just runs on one machine that has a very fast disk
very fast SSD So even if the data goes beyond
the memory of the instance which can very be
uh well the case when you when you think about PA
files being uh decompressed in memory uh you end
up with potentially hundred of of gigabytes
of of of uh data. Uh but for the new engines
since they are streaming based and they they
juggle between um the CPU, the memory and the
disk um this is not an issue at all. Yeah, that's
awesome. So really like new rust based frameworks,
high performance single node, faster disk
spillover, like all these things come together
to really change the paradigm of how we compute.
And so okay, so you've got probably hundreds and
hundreds or maybe thousands of pipelines inside of
Palunteer probably in legacy, you know, the Spark
kind of framework and transforms. And so you kind
of I think we have like rough around about 100,000
builds a day on the platform more or less 100,000.
Yes. Wow. Okay. So huge scale. That's that's
uh awesome. Okay. So hundreds of thousands you can
you can step in my role and say like how can we
make that more efficient, right? And then and then
uh obviously all of that is written in pispark.
Well, not all of it but most of it is written in
pi spark. Um, and that's where um really like the
idea of lightweight came in. Uh, and yeah, I mean
actually it's triggered like by by by by by the
evolution in the field. you see those benchmark
and you see hey why how can we how can we
um uh benefit from this and that's why we I
keep constantly um chasing the palent team
right and saying hey um it's time it's time um
and yeah essentially I think I think that's when
this year or early this year this took off and
um somebody said yeah let's let's do something
um yeah Yeah. No, that's cool. I I love it when
customers push us into new avenues, new areas
based on what you're seeing, what your needs are.
Like the the intersection of hundreds of thousands
of builds a day, uh, and your cost reduction,
like that's huge potential, uh, for you. So,
I could see why you were pushing so hard on that.
Um, and I'm glad you did because now like together
we have created something that's pretty cool
to be able to have any of these different uh,
data and compute engines um, running inside the
platform through lightweight. So as you're down,
okay, so you have hundreds of thousands of builds,
tons of PISpark code, what does it look like to
transform into lightweight transforms for you?
Yeah. So um I want to take a step back. I want
to highlight like what really enabled the new
lightweight for us, right? The new lightweight
experience. And that was basically to to say
the standard should be the S3 API because as
every every framework the best support you get is
for the S3 object store right and and making that
also the interface in lightweight I think that
was the game changer that unlocked all of this
um and not having any proprietary APIs you
know where where Palunteer or you know you
become a bottleneck running behind and say oh we
oh we support this or and then tomorrow there's
a new API. Oh, we need to support there's a
new engine, right? We need to support engine
X engine Y. But like once uh Lightweight moved to
the S3 API or to the what what you call S3 proxy,
right? Um that is the fundamental unlocker here uh
to to leverage any kind of engine. And in our case
um we we are observing uh this space for some
time. Um and and really the the current leader
here when it comes to stability as well and
performance is is stuck db um and have a perfect
and really efficient S3 uh park reader and writer.
And if you have that uh in a lightweight container
um there's not much stopping you from getting
quick builds. Yeah, that's very cool. Okay,
so that fundamental architectural shift unlocked
not only DuckPB but a lot of these other ones to
have better performance, better interoperability.
Exactly. People can bring their own engines now
as well. Um, so but DuckDB specifically has
been pretty fantastic for you from a stability
standpoint as far as you know, no out of memory
issues and things being handled really well from
the stability that opensource. Let me let me
go there a little bit more into detail because
yeah you you asked for it as well. Um for um for
our scale there they there are kind of like two
um uh like it's kind of a distribution of of
jobs, right? At the one end you have the ones
that run multiple hours and uh actually take a
lot of uh compute seconds and a lot of cost in
the end. And then there's the long tail. you have
hundreds that maybe run for a few minutes and but
then maybe also run very often and for both
of them we kind of needed a solution. Um so
um yeah actually um what we created internally in
in my team was a reusable library uh that uses a
open source framework called SQL frame that is
implementing a spy pispar compatible API. So you
can actually take your Pispar code, your existing
Pispar code and translate it or com compile it,
transpile it, how however you want to call it,
right, to SQL to to Suduct DBS SQL. And then we
we hooked in the the inputs from Foundry and the
outputs and um were able to uh first of all give
that to power users that worked on the um high uh
impact data sets that take multiple hours and so
on to build um and are very cost uh highly cost
uh costly on the platform. But at the same time
we were able to give it uh and bring it into
the processes that are highly standardized. Uh,
think about your SAP data sets where you always
need to do the same cleaning steps for string
columns. It's in every data set and there are
literally thousands on the platform because as
a company with a with a legacy, right, you have
we have a lot of SAP systems. Um, yep. And um,
but anyway, all of them need the same cleaning
steps and then you do it once, but then it's a
basically a huge generator of transformations and
and then you roll it out across the board. So,
so those two things is where we where we initially
uh and are now running uh lightweight with stuck
DB in production. Wow. Okay. So, this is in
production. It's across lots of different
modalities that you're kind of testing out. Um
so, like maybe maybe some examples. Do you have
anything we could take a look at as far as some
examples of what this actually looks like? Yeah,
sure. Um we can we can take a look. Um maybe we
we start with um like one of our transforms in
the company uh and the controlling area um where
basically yeah the complete um data supply chain
of of the controlling area is brought together
um and and those jobs they with and and this is
I think with at least eight executors or 16
executors I know it's a little bit small but
they took like you you see um like six, seven
hours here, right? Uh in run. Wow. Um and then
after we migrated here um in in July or in June,
um we are at um uh 26 22 uh u 10 minutes even.
Um if we're lucky. Um so and and this is B this
job is really not like not not a hard one, right?
It's it's a it's union. It's a little bit union of
different data sets, a few filters here and there,
but I think the key difference is that DuckDv is
able to vectorize a lot of instructions um and has
highly efficient like union all capabilities um
that we don't see in in Spark open source. Yeah.
Um and then yeah, you can imagine that for me as a
platform owner this is really nice. Okay. But also
for our controllers or for the head of controlling
or whoever in the end looks at the reports,
the dashboards, the or at the data products, the
AI, whatever is done with this, right? Uh it's a
much uh shorter cycle from from the ingestion to
uh to the actual finished uh end data product.
Yeah. Wow. That's so you're talking 7 8 hours
down to 20 minutes. um if I'm doing my math,
that's more than 10 times on that one alone. But
obviously that's not every use case. It's running
with one node with four or eight CPUs instead of
eight nodes. So it's like maybe it's an extreme
example. Um but um definitely something that that
you see here. But I think that goes goes to your
point though around like just even the engine
optimizations around unions. Like if I don't
have a distributed system, be able to do unions on
a single node is just much more efficient period.
um rather than just you know like all of the
gathering of stuff back together to do a union
is a very expensive operation in a distributed
system. So like those optimizations on top of
the node size it's rust based it's you know all of
these kind of things uh add up to pretty cool use
case like that. So now that you're doing this at
scale like what are you seeing are there things in
palanteer you're still working with us on? Yeah,
I mean first of all we are working together to get
the duct DB integration to be first class, right?
Um I think that's important for me. Uh but also I
think I'm also talking to many other customers
that want it. So um um that's the first thing.
But then at the second uh the second thing is that
I think there are still some um infrastructure um
limits that could be improved uh in the platform.
So this could even be faster. This could be even
faster. That's my my hint. U comparing to like
bare metal performance of these jobs. Um so
that's quite exciting. Um probably like maybe
that's like my personal theory. Nobody has hit
those limits like with the Spark jobs and now um
it's time to to push that barriers as well. No,
that's awesome. This is what I love customers
pushing us to continue to evolve and improve and
so this this is awesome. I think like you said
just like how do we benchmark against you know
what's out there and finding these new new areas
whether you're hitting a new benchmark because of
like crazy high utilization because you're just
hammering these nodes now with duct DB. Um I
I'm very curious what we find there as well. So
you've got some more examples here and it looks
like this one is a build that's happening quite a
bit more often versus other one was kind of once
in a while once a week or so like this build all
the time like this is interesting. It's like what
type of transform is this? Yeah, I think and and
and this one is um also interesting because it's
not like a simple union or so. So it's like a
really complex thousand lines of pispar code
that is being translated to duct DB with SQL
frame and um yeah you you can see clearly see
the impact here going from I would say three one
between one and 3 hours to uh to under under 30
minutes 30 40 minutes but this is run uh at least
every day. Um, so the impact is also multiplied
by the the amount of times this is run. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, that's really cool. So these you're
basically able to just take this library, convert
the pi spark code into lightweight trans into the
lightweight transforms and have duck DB be the
backend engine here and then like you just get
the improvement. Yeah, exactly. I mean this is
an open source library, right? So um you you you
need to know what you sign up for, right? Um but
this is what I love from open sour source right
um we're able to contribute we're able to open
um and same for ductb right same for polas right
um we're able to contribute we're able to provide
um issue descriptions reproducible issues and then
uh and then it's it's getting fixed or we fix it
ourselves right um and and and that's essentially
the beauty about open source yeah very cool and
I see that you've got an M seg Egg tap. Well, I I
know too much about SAP to know MSEG is is one of
the bigger tables and fun ones that Okay. Wow. Uh
that's a pretty big drop. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. So,
I told you about like the long tail, right? The
long tail of of of jobs that are all kind of the
same cleaning jobs and and and you see like this
seems to be um um running very often um according
I I hope there's a valid business need for it.
Um but that's not for me to decide because that's
closer to the use cases to the data products,
right? Not in the platform engineering team.
But you see it's running quite often and after
me we it's even not a it's not like has kept all
the history in this chart. It's only showing the
last 1,000 uh runs. Um but luckily for us in this
in this session that we still see the spark runs
um and you still see that they take like you know
15 16 minutes maybe if we're lucky like 6 minutes
and I I guess you clearly see the migration
point right um and yes and this is now running
with um with uh I mean I have to lie probably
two CPUs and 15 gigs of memory. Wow. Okay. So
that I mean just the the footprint and the speed
here. I think that I mean that's the thing that's
surprising me. It's cuz normally it's like okay
I can speed a job up. I throw more resources. I
take resource away. It slows it down. Seems like
you've got less resources and a faster runtime.
Yeah. I don't know. It sounds too good to be
true. Um yeah but but it actually you can see
it here. It it it actually uh does work. Yeah.
Yeah. Very cool. Awesome. Well, this is this is
really cool stuff. I appreciate you sharing this
with me. Is there other things um you know in the
future that you're excited about this transition
or like are you going to continue kind of pushing
us for performance other things and then you know
migrating more and more jobs or what's your what's
your bigger vision with this? Yeah. So yeah,
so I'm I'm really excited about the like the
future in in this space as also in the kind of
lakeost space right because uh with iceberg um
so I'm not only managing like foundry right also
other data platforms and and with iceberg for the
first time there is a protocol there's a standard
uh even though it's definitely not perfect but um
all of us can somehow uh agree on and with foundry
having embraced iceberg and yeah I'm working with
with with with your colleagues on testing it and
and and uh and adopting it um but then also with
the other vendors um and and that's really great
because that allows us to pick the right engine
for the right job um ultimately um maybe it's
duct DV maybe it's some other cloud data warehouse
um but in the end we can decide uh based on our
prerequisites, based on our skill set, what is the
right tool to pick uh to provide the most value
for for for the business. Definitely. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm excited about iceberg as well. Like I think
there's a lot of cool stuff that's going to be
coming there. Um but I think I mean your your
description right there is the thesis behind
the multimodal data plane is like any storage,
any compute, anywhere. Yeah. Sometimes I think
it's because of us. I don't know. Um because you
know it's definitely not. I'm just joking Chad.
It's definitely um like we have I we have we write
like since since virtual tables are there right
we write to big query we read from bigquery with
virtual we have snowflake read right to snowflake
AWS iceberg glue catalog all of that we have in
production and it it wasn't possible two years
ago not at all I mean just with maybe with a lot
of hacks but uh but today it's supported and it
really allows us to to build this ecosystem
here at Merc this platform ecosystem that
truly integrates them. Um and and that's what I'm
excited about. Yeah. Um real enterprises have very
comp especially enterprises of your size have very
complex heterogeneous architectures that have been
through acquisitions and time and all sorts of
stuff. And it's like yeah in a perfect world you
replatform everything and have some clean slate
but that's never going to happen. And so like how
do you embrace the chaos? And it's like okay let's
actually give you the tools to to manage that. And
so that's that's cool that you're really starting
to see that and embrace that across uh everything
you're doing. So I really appreciate you taking
the time to to show me and and everybody the the
cool stuff that you're doing. Like I I just also
value your partnership here of like pushing us and
seeing what is going on in the field, what's
working. Like this is exciting to me. I can I
think you can tell I'm excited because like I've
been doing this data pipelining stuff for 15 20
years as well. And like this is truly cool to be
able to see both cost reduction and speed up out
of a simple like addictive like when you do those
migrations. Um and it's also everyone benefits
because it's not like um we don't have enough
use cases, right? Uh we need the room. We need
the room to build new stuff, right? And to build
AI use cases and to leverage AIP and all of that.
uh which which would be very hard if we
we keep like going with with Spark engines
uh all of the time. Yeah. Yeah. Awesome. Well,
thanks again. I appreciate it. I really enjoyed
the conversation, Nicholas. Thanks, Chad. Uh
thanks for the invite again. Appreciate it.